But also, more interestingly, has the __data__ property,
which corresponds to an object.
Opening up that object, we see we have the fields of a single row
from our data file, which we saw earlier, as the .enter selection.
But now instead of corresponding to only __data__ with
the fields, it now is actually bound to a circle.
So the combination of the enter selection with the append,
merges the data from our data file, with the svg circle element.
And this is where the mysterious data of d3's magical data bound lives.
It's simply, a JavaScript object,
attached as a property to the svg node, living in the DOM.
And as we can see here, on the left again is the selection of what
lives on the page either as HTML or SVG.
Starting with the select of the parent SVG element, which contained in it has
a SVG circle element, for each row of our data file, worldcup.tsv.
Which d3 binds with it's data function, as we can see here corresponding
to the link, to a row of our file which was loaded and stored in the data
variable which again is a single row from our worldcup.tsv data file.
So think of these linkages, as the magic data bind.
Everything on the left side, as what's present on the page.
Either as SVG or HTML.
And everything on the right side, as either a JavaScript object, or
some piece of our data file.
And here, I represent all 836 rows simply by the dotted arrow, which
means that this extends all the way down, binding every row to every circle.
If any of this was unclear, I encourage you to read through Mike's post on
the subject, which is contained in the lecture notes.
Or if you want a more complete treatment of the subject, look at the book
reference in the lecture notes, Virtual Storytelling With D3, by Richie S King,
which inspired this graphic and explanation, of the mysterious databind process.